if you're an architect user looking for
a brand new laptop in
2021 you found the perfect video
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about technology and architecture
as of right now in 2021 i'm a registered
architect
in the state of western australia and
today we are talking about the perfect
laptop for people using
archicad now in particular we're going
to be talking about archicad 24 and the
requirements of archicad 24.
at the same time i'm going to be taking
into consideration the requirements for
twin motion
so let's go through them one by one
we're gonna break this down into three
categories
one basic residential two apartment and
office design and three
high-rise and hospitals basically
starting with the low
easy to maintain jobs that don't require
a lot of power all the way to the
premium
high-end jobs that require all the
performance that you could possibly ask
for
and you should probably get a desktop
okay so let's start with basic
residential laptops
these are all just recommendations i do
strongly suggest you go out and do
further research before you select
one the first laptop i do suggest is the
microsoft
surface laptop 3 with an i5 processor
and 256 gigabytes
of storage the light slim ergonomic
design with extremely long battery life
makes it the perfect laptop
for anybody looking to travel and do
architecture
or engineering at the same time the
surface laptop comes in at 1199
australian dollars
and it is up there in price the second
laptop i recommend for basic residential
is the brand new m1 apple macbook pro
now i've started testing the mac
m1 and it is doing phenomenally well in
the archicad software i haven't started
testing it for twin motion and rendering
just yet
but for archicad alone it is doing great
the macbook pro also comes in at 1999
australian dollars
so it is the same price as the surface
laptop 3.
we have windows and we have a mac option
now the third and final laptop in this
category is the huawei
mate book it is very powerful for what
it is for 1272
i believe it is right now in australia
it is very cheap
and practical it's light it's powerful
and it can last a long time
so for twelve hundred dollars it is a
good introductory model
however i haven't tested this model
fully so i don't know if it is a hundred
percent compatible with arc cad and
doesn't have any issues
however being a windows pc i don't see
it having too many issues
moving on to apartments and offices
usually if you're doing apartments and
offices you still have that luxury of
moving around
traveling and needing your laptop
outside of the office
so these recommendations are truly based
on versatile
and portable laptops believe it or not
the macbook pro
m1 boosted up to the 512 gigabytes of
storage
is the perfect choice here the m1 chips
are outperforming everything else i'm
testing at the moment
a mac mini is outperforming my desktop
at the moment which is incredibly
surprising
so the m1 chips are truly showing their
own in these
graphic intensive programs the price
only goes up 2
29 so it isn't a huge jump forward
from its predecessor in the basic
residential category the next step
up is obviously the surface laptop 3
again but with an i7 processor
and 512 gigabytes of ram it does
significantly take a jump up in price to
3400
now i do recommend the amd over the i7
intel chip
for the simple fact that the multi-core
performance on an amd
surface laptop 3 is significantly better
than it is on the intel
chips whilst archicad does run well of
single core performance it predominantly
uses the multi-core stats and finally if
the surface pro
is too far out of your price range the
dell xps 15.6 laptop
is the perfect choice it comes in at
hundred and ninety nine dollars
now having said all this and
recommending these six laptops so far
i do truly believe that you need 512
gigabytes
regardless of what category you're
working in
even if you're doing basic residential i
do recommend 512 gigabytes of storage
just to make sure you don't under
capitalize
you really want to be able to install as
many programs as you need and not have
to worry about deleting data off your
laptop now third and final is
the most expensive category and it is
absolutely ridiculous
personally i wouldn't buy a laptop if
you're doing high-rise or
hospitals for example because they
require so much power and
it's just so expensive so my
recommendation is always a desktop but
if you
have to purchase a laptop i have two
recommendations for you
now all of these have extremely long
names because they're gaming laptops
so i'm going to read them directly not
to screw them up the first
is the asus republic of gaming scar 4
g5 3 2 it has 64 gigabytes of ram and an
i9
processor it is theoretically meant to
be able to handle
anything you throw at it however i do
see this as potentially flawed because
it is extremely bulky extremely heavy
comes in at about six kilos and is
constantly required to be charged
because it is
so powerful and draining so much power
the next laptop
is ridiculously overpriced it is the msi
g566 stealth 10uh041au
it also has an i9 processor 2 terabytes
of ssd storage
only 32 gigabytes of ram it does have a
4k display
but at the same time it costs 5999
australian dollars
that is absurd the desktop you see
behind me
only cost two and a half thousand for
the tower itself
and then about another thousand for the
peripherals so if you went out and spent
three and a half thousand on a desktop
similar to this
you could absolutely obliterate any of
these laptops
however there is a purpose for all of
these devices especially
if you are working on project files like
a hospital hospitals can be huge and
they
can take up terabytes of space so
having something that has two terabytes
of ssd built in
might unfortunately be the only device
for you
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
today this video falls under one of my
28 videos in
28 days so usually it'll be i'll see you
next monday but because it is february
i'll see you tomorrow